good morning John it occurs to me that
there are a lot of things that I haven't
told you about in my life so I'm gonna
make a video in which we catch up thing
number one you may remember a while back
the Katherine and I were fostering a
greyhound of the hopes that we would get
to keep her however would the people at
the adoption agency came by to see how
she was doing and saw the way that she
was looking at our cat which is
apparently the way that you know I look
at a quarter pound double stack with
cheese from Wendy's they said that that
particular dog would have to find a home
that did not have little furry friends
living in it which has already happened
in that wonderful dog has a wonderful
home down the valley so Katherine and I
had to wait for a better time for a new
shipment of retired racing greyhounds to
come in to Missoula which they did and
we adopted this lovely dog who is
extremely sweet her track name was Tina
Fey and we have named her lemon and
she's sleeping right next to me right
now here she is she likes to be as close
to us as possible thing number two
retired racing greyhounds are really
great dogs and if you're in the market
for a new dog you should check and see
if there is an adoption agency that
specializes in greyhounds nearby you
because there are a lot of greyhounds
they could retire from tracks and are
not able to get adopted into homes thing
number three after lemon poops she just
she's the happiest it's the happiest
time of her day which makes me very
nostalgic for the days in which I used
to enjoy pooping but on a good note I've
been feeling much better lately and I
have managed to get a new prescription
for a new kind of drug which is like
half as much as the old one the price of
my drugs went from 385 a month to 458 a
month by the end of this year one year
that is a huge increase but now there's
this new drug which is like half the
cost hopefully they won't keep raising
the price of that a hundred percent
every year thing number four I really
hate it when I'm watching the show on my
computer on full screen and then the
show fades to black and then suddenly I
can see my reflection in the monitor
when I see that slack dull face just
staring at itself I just want a snap out
of it and go do something with my life
but then I know that I can't because you
know I'm in the middle of a show thing
number five
Kathryn brought this up the other day
and I just want to bring it the idea to
light why don't we have water beds that
double as aquariums thing number six one
time I left a pot of ramen noodles
boiling and then all the water boiled
away and then the wrong
noodle caught on fire thing number seven
we might think that the Super Bowl is a
big deal here in America but hockey five
percentages is a much bigger deal in
Canada were around 80 percent of the
population watched the final Olympic
hockey game
Air Canada had to delay a flight because
the passengers refused to get on board
while the hockey game was still going on
and check out this cough of Edmonton's
water used during the Olympic hockey
final yeah that's a lot of people not
peeing and then having to pee thing
number eight the winners of the Harry
Potter Alliance helping Haiti heal
raffle have been announced so if you
participated in that raffle you will
have received an email saying that you
won a thing if you want to think but the
nerdfighter related prizes were a song
by me about you was won by Samantha
Samantha I'm gonna write a song about
you sign copies of all of my CDs was won
by Samuel in Pennsylvania the John Green
three book package was won by flower
child headbands which I'm sure is
probably exactly what it sounds like and
a 1000 words short story written by a
New York Times bestselling author on the
topic of your choosing was won by Nancy
from San Francisco we will be contacting
all of you soon
congratulations helping ad heal five
planes full of aid supplies are already
on their way you didn't forget to be
awesome John I will see you on Monday